[Music]
hey everyone good day welcome to culture
binge the wisecrack podcast where we go
deep on everything happening in the
current cultural moment I am Michael and
I'm joined by wisecrack writer Alec and
wisecrack researcher sir B how are you
all doing on this fine day
very well how are you you know fine
dealing with with bad internet speeds
but besides that really doing great so I
don't think we need to waste any time
other than to say we have a lot to talk
about today and as always we need to
start by talking about what is slapping
and chatting in the lives of everyone
who is currently here my preference is
always to start with sir B so unless
anyone has a problem with that
sir B what is slapping and chatting
since we've last seen you so what slaps
is I love shits Creek it is such a good
show it makes me so happy I haven't
watched the final season yet because I I
feel like I've been saving it um and it
just it just fills my heart with so much
joy so I love shits Creek what chaps is
my computer died so I realized how I'm
so connected to the world through one
computer all my passwords are stored on
that computer every every like website
everything I feel so disconnected feel
very lost without my computer wow that's
rough Wow
um Alec how are you what is slapping
what is champing I have to say nothing's
really bad this week but also nothing's
wrong both are extremely Petty and lame
I'm gonna sort of the lame one which is
what slaps is I discovered I guess
skiers use this like anti-fog droplets
to put on the inside your glasses so
when you're wearing a mask it doesn't
fog up it's amazing I can ride my bike
if I'm asked like is suggested it's
small small victories in life that being
said I don't really have much to
complain about so again extra petty but
small sure
running around without masks I don't
want to say I hate them but they are
tiny little monsters that are vectors of
disease so you know I know if they're
under two or they don't have to but
listen you're eight year old trying to
like steal the rocks off my picnic
blanket needs to chill the [ __ ] out
wow that's so specific stealing the
rocks off of your picnic blanket it was
really cute
okay so it's both cute and Alec
officially hates children normal stuff
okay so I'll go quick so slaps I have
recently started taking not taking
online music lessons but watching these
online guitar courses I play guitar my
whole life but really fallen off
recently but decided to get back into it
since I have more time and I'm bored and
I have found it one of the most
satisfying things of the past you know
eight to ten weeks going through these
courses learning new stuff I feel like
my brain is expanding like new synaptic
connections are being made as I learn
things so it's been a nice feeling I
have a question yes mister have you how
many times have you showed up to a party
and played hey there Delila with your
acoustic guitar now once in my life
here's here's the best thing I could say
about myself as a quality I don't love I
don't like myself very much but one
thing I like about myself I have played
guitar since I was about 10 years old I
am significantly older than 10 now I
have almost never in my life been the
guy to take a guitar out at a party if
I'm in someone's house and they like a
guitar there I'm not like oh cool can I
check this out I'm just gonna strum for
a sec hate that person would never be
that person so know that at least you
can invite me someplace and I won't take
a guitar out that's good to know also
good to know is due to by its thank you
for donating yes I'm trying to read what
they're saying before I read it in case
it's foul or something do divides would
never more never Oh better weather after
four days of rain but may have to
evacuate a home due to four dams failing
what the [ __ ] oh yeah he's from which no
sorry if I'm not supposed to say this
but he I know that do divides us from
Michigan and this this this dam broke
there on its it's crazy I read about
this last night oh is this the one where
it's like eight feet of lettuce or
something
yes do bite stay
safe at all cost if you are in Michigan
protect dude abides at all cost
speaking I guess have negative things
then of chaps I guess this is kind of
similar to Alex on what chaps my ass is
I was on a hike with my partner on
Sunday to be clear safe hike we're
wearing masks not a lot of people around
but the vibe on the hike was you know
you'd have your mask on maybe you don't
see someone for like five minutes so you
pull it down a little bit but if you see
someone in the distance even a little
speck you get that mask back up at one
point we turned this corner and an older
gentleman is kind of coming at us so we
both pull lightly pull our masks up he
is an unmasked gentleman he leans in
towards us sneezes on us and goes oh I
hope I don't get you sick it sucked I
didn't like it it made me mad you told
me this yesterday and I thought about it
in the shower and it just made me very
angry like I want to find that person
yeah on his house and kill his whole
family yeah yeah um and my partner is a
kind-hearted person she's she's she's a
poet she's a gentle spirit but I had to
talk her down from like straight up
trying to murder this person it sucked
really bad and I guess did trying to be
like empathetic to some extent I guess
maybe this is a stupid old person whose
vibe was like he thought that us putting
masks on was like you're gross so we
don't want you to breathe on us not
understanding we were doing it for him
in case we're the sick carriers of
disease but it really it really sucked
it was it was a really it was just a big
bummer don't do that I didn't like it it
really kind of kind of ruined my whole
day so that's that so what was we yeah
it sucked we have a lot of talked about
today so I know I'm gonna later talk a
little bit about some of the more recent
conspiracy theories taking over your
parents and aunts and uncles Facebook
feeds house is gonna talk to us about
some sort of theater that happens
involving security and sir be you I
guess they're just gonna gush about a
friend named Karen today if I understand
correctly so sir me take it away tell us
what's up with Karen so Karen so the
term Karen first came into my orb
a few years ago when I had the worst
haircut of my life it was so awful that
are you a Karen is what you're saying
Wow oh no no I'm not we already know you
hate tipping so this is all making sense
now okay first of all I need to clear
the air on the tipping thing my problem
is with the American system of tipping
that we are obligated to supplement
other people's income I feel like we
should just have a culture where we pay
everyone a great wage so that I as a
consumer don't feel obligated to pay for
them I both agree with that and I'm
suspicious of going out to dine with you
I do very well because I know that it's
very challenging but it's always like I
just wish you got paid better so this
way you're not like forced to like yeah
be nice [ __ ] and we all we all agree
with that but before I'm just kidding
you're not I will get there so I had a
Karen haircut and my friend said that I
looked like the most Karen Karen so I
was like what is the Karen and I learned
that a Karen is a term used to describe
someone who is demanding or entitled and
is usually directed towards white
middle-aged American women who behave
aggressively when they don't get their
way so black communities have used the
concept of a Karen for years to identify
white women to be wary of because
they'll likely wield their privilege at
the expense of others
Meredith Clark a media researcher at the
University of Virginia states that the
cultural reference has always been there
it just hasn't always been so specific
to one person's name karen has gone by
different names back in the 90s when
baby got back came out it was Becky
there will be another name so how did
Karen go from this like cultural warning
to a meme well a few years ago our
editor started posting these stories
about his ex-wife Karen
that turned into a meme which turned
into a term that people now find
derogatory classist racist sexist Aegeus
all this and i'm not making light of it
there there are really great arguments
that Karen is like a code word for [ __ ]
or like a horrible girl or something
like that so I do think there is like a
good argument for that anyway Heather
Suzanne woods is a meme researcher and
professor at Kansas State University
what a great job a meme researcher yeah
living the dream and she's a meme
researcher yeah and she states that the
essence of Karen's is entitlement
selfishness and a desire to complain she
states that a Karen demands the world
exists according to her standards with
little regard for others and she's
willing to risk or demean others to
achieve her ends so as I said Karen's
have been around forever but more
recently karen has been used to describe
women who are opposed to social
distancing these new coronavirus Karen's
are thought to hoard toilet paper and
other essential supplies they demand
that stay-at-home orders are lifted they
hold signs that declare their disbelief
in science and their strong desire to
get a haircut so that's the story of a
Karen and the new rise and Karen's and I
want to know what you do think is having
the term Karen useful to identify and
prevent toxic behavior because research
has shown that public publicly shaming
people is a useful way to curb bad
behavior have you ever met a Karen do
you think Karen is a derogatory term do
you think that Karen's are more on the
rise or that were more aware of bad
behavior what are your thoughts on
Karen's I definitely don't think it's a
derogatory term I'm just gonna say that
I think that it's ridiculous to think
that it's derogatory and people it is
derogatory it's a derogatory that we're
cool with yeah let me rephrase it is a
dope derogatory term that everyone
should use on no but I mean there was
like you know
and tweets going around about people
that were earnestly comparing it to the
N word which is one of the most
ridiculous things I've ever heard so I
think in that sense it is not okay about
this it's derogatory it's not a slur and
I think there's been discussion that the
word carrion is a slur I don't know it's
it's an accurate descriptor of a
particular type of person and cultural
phenomenon they exist to say that one is
a Karen or the Karen's exist isn't to
say that like everyone else is good or
that like all dudes are good or
something like that far from it but it
is a great descriptor and as soon as you
learn what a Karen is your brain
immediately is like oh yeah
that makes sense I have always needed a
term for this thing and I will simply
say someone who lives in Southern
California there they exist you see them
a lot I have been at many a restaurant
where I've seen a Karen doing Karen
things I've even been out with groups
before where there is unbeknownst to me
it carried in the group and I have to
pull the thing where like maybe later in
the evening I'm kind of walking to the
bathroom at a restaurant and I have to
like get catch the server and be like
hey by the way I'm so sorry for
so-and-so we don't normally hang out
with them that's ridiculous
my bad let us buy you a drink at the end
of this because you got it sometimes
cover up the Karen's mess Alec what do
you think about these the Karen on
existence of the Karen I mean I think
like any term it's liable to sort of
mutate into things that like might end
up being super shitty but I think like
the core definition that we're going
with is fine and I think like i-i've
been thinking a little bit just about
like different words that people don't
like and why they don't like them and I
think what what kind of not fully
defines a slur but like even the word
like [ __ ] often gets used to describe
women who are just like being vocal or
assertive like things that are not bad
but as long as Karen only means like a
woman middle age etcetera who's like
terrorizing serviceworkers I'm fine with
it right I mean even like you know that
the N word would get deployed to
describe like
a personal call we're trying to like go
above their social station right so like
the behavior that the slur is targeting
is not something that's inherently bad
where's I think we can all agree that
you know [ __ ] on service workers who
are often themselves like white people
is bad so is there a male equivalent of
a caring because I've seen men [ __ ] on
service workers yeah well I'm all about
yeah there's Kyle but I don't know if
Kyle's quite the same
there's also God there's another one god
no so a Chad is a a Chad as a bro but
there
Chad's are awful in their own way but
they're not for the same reasons but
yeah I I think there probably should be
or maybe we should just use the word
Karen for males and females who are
terrorizing you know restaurant staff I
know lots of boomer aged men who do
think Karen like things yeah I think
there's like in a certain sense I think
you know we have a more general
understanding that that men are kind of
just like that but you know we have like
the frat bros stereotype we have the
finance bro thing we have terms like
douchebag and [ __ ] like I do think
there is a decent if we don't have the
exact term for it a cultural
understanding that there is a certain
type or certain types of terrible men in
many scenarios that we don't have to to
stretch to imagine so I I don't think I
don't think the underlying logic and I
guess I say this is a dude so is that
you know it's not like the underlying
assumption is that all men and
especially white men are good and then
there's like this certain type of white
women who are the bad ones I think it's
just describing a very particular
phenomenon of this moment I also think
you know it's soon like I wouldn't want
the term care like sometimes you're at a
restaurant you have to politely bring up
things like hey I'm so sorry there's a
hair in life I wouldn't want Karen to be
like weaponized as a way and the same
thing with like boomer I'm happy to make
fun of boomers all day but you know
sometimes the term is inappropriate so
I've been called a Karen before yeah and
I love how you're like yeah naturally I
I'm mostly joking although I've never
been in a public place of the so I am I
I'm not like when I used to be one of
those people who like when something
went wrong or I had really horrible
customer service I would just feel
really terrible about it all day and
like beat myself up about it but now I'm
not like that and I'll say something
like that I was very rude of you to
speak to me that way
and I wish that you would have been
kinder and people are like oh that was
really caring and I'm like was it though
like to identify that somebody was
unkind and rude and to point out that
they work in a public-facing role and
they should exhibit more professional
behaviors that maybe somebody in the
back office wouldn't have to and always
you're talking about in like a corporate
environment no like retail even like if
I'm like at a shop or something and
someone's like rude to me I'm like mmm
no yeah I and I think that's where it
gets tricky right when I think it's fine
if someone's super super shitty to be
like hey excuse me
yeah there's obviously sort of like a
tactfulness tactful way to do it in an
appropriate way to do it without
screaming which I think would not make
someone a Karen but then the term like
obviously would get sort of weaponized
against you and so yeah I definitely get
that and to be clear I do it to
everybody it's not just like I reserved
this like these moments for retail
workers no I do it to my colleagues to
it I'm like hey you're an [ __ ] but I
say in a more professional way when
service workers are mean mostly waiters
are mean to me I am like please like me
I'll do anything for you to like me in
fact one of my favorite god I hope it's
so open after Corona there's a bar in
Manhattan called Spain you'll walk in
there it's like walking into 1980 the
year there's these like octogenarian
waiters who are all I believe from Spain
I like they speak with a Spanish accent
and they just there's free tapas as long
as you're drinking and like you know the
thing where it's like hey I love a beer
oh I'll have that beer too and then
everyone goes around the waiter they
don't do that they're just like how many
and then you'll start doing that the
back No
how many and they will not get you your
[ __ ] drinks until you give them an
actual number and then when the tapas
already they just like throw them at you
anyway
I love those guys and I want them to do
my best friends I would never I I'm a
hunter isn't with you in this case if
I'm ever in a setting where a server or
a bartender seems cranky and I'm going
to make you love me and I'll do whatever
I can sort of like sacrificially ending
my own life for you yeah and I think too
like with anything it's a service point
I think if I'm in a case where someone
who has like a powerful position and
like makes a lot of money or I assume
they make a lot of money if they're a
dick I'm more likely to respond with a
little righteous indignation if it's a
setting more like a barista or someone
who is making like a low-wage amount of
money is kind of cranky I'm like [ __ ] it
they're not making that much to do this
job
a lot of not to get to down like a
rabbit hole but a lot of people working
jobs they don't get paid a lot and
there's a lot of emotional labor
attached to that occasionally like you
know if I ever am using public
transportation again if like a bus
driver is cranky for all I know this
person just had to kick someone off two
stops back for like [ __ ] in their
seat so I don't know if they don't seem
like too excited about me having the
wrong change that could have happened 10
minutes ago so Who am I to like be like
excuse me sir I am a paying customer but
I get what you're saying yeah yeah I
think there were like degrees of it like
you can like identify like okay what is
like totally outside the realm of
empathy and understanding and then
that's when I speak up anyway back to
the Karen situation have either of you
felt like you were a Karen where you've
just totally lost your mind do you
empathize it all with Karen not even a
little bit misunderstood I have to be
honest I truly do not think in my entire
life I've acted in many unfortunate and
inappropriate ways in my life I don't
think I've ever acted like a Karen so
that's I think that is why I have such
little empathy for it I don't think I've
ever been mean to a customer service
person I've never been mean to a server
or a barber or a grocery store worker I
just had
done it and that that has to do maybe
some of my issues but I've done it yeah
I used to work in restaurants as you
know like pre-college and so like even
when the service is awful I'm a little
just like making excuses like it'll be
two hours and like sorry the kitchens
back tomorrow I make sense like it's not
your fault
even at the point like not only why
would I have I ever been like
confrontational and I think I've said
this before the service could be like
two-hour wait awful and like I'm so mad
I'm gonna leave them 15% and then I
always rationalize my way about I'll
give them 18% yeah I agree I don't find
I can't emphasize it all with karyn's I
I realize like I don't like going out
with my friends anymore to like
restaurants and stuff or to like places
because I might discover that they are
caring and then I don't like them as
much and it makes me really sad for
example a few months ago I had a friend
come visit and she received the wrong
drink she got like a drink to goblins
who gives make happen yeah and like she
was like oh this is disgusting and I'm
like oh is not that's not the right tea
like we could go back and get get the
tea that you wanted I'm sure they won't
mind and she goes back and she just laid
into this girl and I was like he's a
mystique like it's okay and I like kind
of like mouthed sorry to the girl and
like afterwards I talked to my friend
and was like hey that's not like very
nice of you to do that um and she's like
well it was the wrong tea and I'm like
yeah but think about it it's a [ __ ]
tea like did you need to gather her
about a tea
no I like to propose a theory of the
Karen which is probably similar to
theories about conspiracy theories and
lots of other things I've said which is
that I feel like our society forces us
to like cling on to any sense of like
control normalcy power agency whatever
and so like you know if you're a
middle-aged woman with like a shitty
husband and like the only thing you got
going for you is like your status and
like your money and I'm not forgiving
the the behave
it's like I know one way to sort of feel
like I'm in control of my life is to
just terrorize service workers which is
obviously bad but I think like it's the
logic of well anyway sorry yeah well I
think one thing worth saying to any
Karen's out there listening or watching
or like people who are caring curious
one of the biggest things to realize is
even if you're not a person that has a
fundamental ethical Drive let's say
you're a very selfish person I'll grant
that you're still making the wrong
choice by being a carry and I'll tell
you why if you are in a service
environment you get the wrong thing and
you're a dick about it
your best case scenario is someone but
grudgingly get you a new thing your
worst case scenario if someone does [ __ ]
to your food later you actively get bad
service other people suffer because of
you now if you get serve the wrong thing
or the wrong drink and you're just cool
as [ __ ] about it and you're apologetic
you're just like not your fault not a
big deal qumola you are likely to get
good service in some cases you're likely
to get some free [ __ ] because of that I
can't say how many times I've been in a
service setting where something is wrong
and rather than being dicks we're just
cool about it later in the night someone
comes over and like hey I got you guys
around a drink sorry about that earlier
and if you're like not a big deal you
have 20 tables in a crowded restaurant
it doesn't matter so I just think like
even if you're just looking at this from
a purely selfish standpoint it's it just
doesn't work out to be a Karen it only
works out if it's about you're kind of
like self-important anger so I just say
don't do it but that's just me that's
just me Karen I'm not even once
yeah any final thoughts on the Karen
lifestyle don't be a Garen Howard do you
agree to that we should not be Karen's I
agree yeah and you know well obviously
we say this all the time well we'll give
you our email address and number at the
end if you do have your own Karen
stories or anecdotes we would obviously
love it to hear them so the next thing
on the docket is Alec you're going to
talk to us about security theater now in
my mind this is a community theater
group that's people that do private
security it malls and corporate parks
that use the
beater to express themselves well it's
hot cops that's people dressed up as
cool ups and shorts so secure so the the
thing that sort of prompted all of this
is I read an article in Gizmodo by Jody
Serrano the headline is in bid to make
passengers feel safer tsa prepares to
screen temperatures at airports and I
think one of the really operative things
is all the language and here used by
people is like to feel safe and I'll
explain what security theaters in a
second but I just want to read a little
bit from it airlines have been pushing
for temperature checks at airports in
order to mitigate passenger fears about
the novel coronavirus and sorry and keep
people that could possibly be ill off
the planes now on its face that seems
smart you know you're running a fever
you could possibly have CO vid don't
spread to other people however as you
read the article this is what it says
scientists at the Centers for Disease
Control and Prevention that's the CDC is
opposed to screen passengers that the
airport has tried to persuade the White
House to reconsider the plan thermal
plant there's a quote thermal scanning
is proposed as a poorly designed control
and detection strategy as we have
learned very clearly said dr. Martin
Ketron the CDC director of global
mitigation quarantine in an email to the
DHS officials earlier this month we
should be concentrating our CDC
resources where the impact and
probability sorry where there is impact
and a probability of mission success I'd
read either here or elsewhere that there
was one sort of pilot where they scanned
like 30,000 people and didn't find one
didn't stop one sort of kovat patient
even though someone tested you know
positive later obviously asymptomatic
carriers is a big deal and so I don't
even it's not even that temperature
scanning is bad maybe if it can catch a
certain percentage of people but
specifically with airline flying the
term security theater gets thrown around
as security that is there for show but
not to actually make people safer and so
what I think is really interesting about
this article is that it's airlines
pushing for this right the airlines that
are losing millions and millions of
dollars in revenue because people are
too scared to fly understandably so and
so you know I'm sure if they
had a magic bullet to solve the the
kovat situation they would do that and
everyone feel safe it would be great but
in absence of that they're gonna go for
strategies that won't actually make
people safer but will make them feel
safer so security theater is this idea
that comes up a lot with the TSA and so
it comes out this guy Bruce Schneier if
I'm pronouncing that wrong Bruce I
apologize but there's a quote security
theater refers to security measures that
make people feel more secure without
doing anything to actually improve their
security an example the photo ID checks
that have sprung up sprung up in office
buildings no one has ever explained why
verifying that someone has a photo ID
provides any actual security but it
looks like security to have a uniformed
guard for hire looking ID cards I used
to work in a dorm this is absolutely
true like if you you have to swipe in
your card but like the security guards
were explicitly told not to pursue
people or get up from their desk but not
allowed to fight people best-case
scenario they can call the cops will
come in 30 minutes but anyway another
great example with the TSA is the body
scanners I didn't know this but you know
the ones where you people well formerly
used to get to sort of see an outline of
your gross naked body um they don't work
what yeah so there was this so there's a
few things going on here one there was
this blogger who like sewed so if it was
at the right angle like if it was
looking sideways that a gun it would not
detect the guy and so this one is one
blog or so metal objects so this secret
is to put it in your side pockets don't
obviously don't put anything your side
but he sewed metal objects into his side
pockets and just like recorded himself
going through multiple airport but then
to corroborate this there was a sort of
tell-all from a former TSA official not
TSA official sorry a TSA officer who
when he went through the training for
these devices like he essentially like
asked the person like a man does this
work he's like now there there's other
there it gets way worse 2017 the
Homeland Security inspectors were able
to transpose transport facsimile
firearms I think that means fake
explosives and Ives through TSA
checkpoints at an appalling 70 percent
of the time
so there's also the argument that the
TSA has never actually stopped a
terrorist attack now the TSA well we
don't we're not gonna advertise that
it's like national security like we
wouldn't tell you but if you look at
that what the TSA does and press
releases on the internet every time they
find anything they're like guys guys we
found a gun and it's always like some
boomer brought a gun onto a plane and
they're all like hey you can't do that
can you check it please and what go okay
so arguably the GSA has never stopped a
security sorry has never stopped a
terrorist attack arguably yeah it's
arguable I'm not gonna deny that they're
very bad at their job yet we take off
our shoes are banned from bringing
liquids go through these security scans
that are probably wildly ineffectual
all to make us feel safer in in light of
terrorism and this is what sort of
critics of this critics of the TSA are
saying is that security theater and so
obviously there's real things that make
us safe from from you know terrorists or
kovat or other things and I'm not trying
to hate on those and I think temperature
checks maybe fall in a gray area but I
think you know it's probably being done
disingenuously by Airlines to give us
the feeling of safe miss what do you
guys think because what if you're like
what is what is like a high temperature
because some people might just run
really hot I run really cold like I'm
always like 97 degrees or whatever so
they might think your dad knows you have
been dead for days
we need to take you off this flight
exactly so what if you just run really
hot or what if you just like have like a
bit of a fever I don't think this is
great if I could miss my flight because
I have a bit of a cold yeah I mean it's
a hard one because then I think is it
like is this just a matter of the
performativity of institutions wanting
to convince us they do much more than
they do while creating the psychological
effect of convincing us that there's
much more control over these things than
just the open anxiety if like the person
on the flight next you might have a gun
in there the pocket of their baggy jeans
or something I know it's one of those
weird trade-offs because I think there's
a lot of
people who could expand could accept the
level of risks and I feel like there's a
whole other part of the population that
like needs this sort of thing that needs
to have their anxieties performative ly
alleviated at all cost and I don't know
I don't know if it'd be worth the
downside of those people being able to
openly freak out or or you know sort of
convince themselves that everyone on the
flight next to them has a gun or
something yeah I do want to take a
slight detour to our favorite state
which is Florida MA
yeah this hasn't been written about but
you know you think about the gated
community where old people like my
grandparents go to feel safe they've
been burgled like five times
you know and they have like these
expensive home security systems that
always go off like 18 million times a
day and they're always calling and you
know it's never stopped any of these
things no at no point has any of their
robbers been caught has it been
prevented by any of these things but I
do think that there is the argument that
I part of security theater is good
because it calls those anxieties at the
same time I don't know yeah I mean I
think and then of course it creates that
and not to go too far down this rabbit
hole can create that awkward vibe of
control as well like when we think about
security theater being used in like
schools for example there's public
schools that have metal detectors and
stuff like that I think then that
creates this low-key like prison control
vibe I think even in airports sometimes
you know the difference between flying
pre and post 9/11 it a lot scarier and
more controlled and and and more like
there's like this increased police and
security presence that not to be like a
libertarian bro about it we should
figure out a name for that guy
maybe it's like Lance but but I think
that's one of the downsides of it is
that that feeling that we're
increasingly moving towards some sort of
surveillance control state environments
in which even if it is just theater it
creates the psychological effect
being watched being under control and
that's that's not the best yeah I want
one thing I found was researching this
this morning is that some of the
programs seem very ineffective at
catching terrorists but like very
effective at catching other people so
there is I think it's called spot or
something like that it's essentially
like a registry of people who shouldn't
be that you want a screen extra or can't
fly or whatever anyway it turns out
people involved in actual terrorist
attacks had like phone several times
unabated and I that the TSA but people
they were catching were like you know
people from South America involved in
the drug trade
and you know I'm not like rushing to
like defend you know like a cocaine
smuggler or something like that but even
in schools like the metal detectors not
exactly stopping at school shooting but
like is causing a lot of kids to go to
jail for [ __ ] who then they own the
records and can't get jobs and all this
[ __ ] yeah I think that's the thing it's
like you don't want the other things
that get caught up in the fishing net
are often the the adverse effects of
this sorry sorry you it's like you're
about to say something incredible I
don't I don't think that we should
enable this sort of thing like I have
anxiety at baseline but I actively try
not to feed into it because the more you
do it the worse it gets and if we have
like this security theater where we just
try to like make people feel less
anxious or afraid then what's next like
I already have to take off my shoes and
now I'm gonna have to get my temperature
checked am I gonna have to have like a
full-body pat-down yeah yeah maybe the
alternative is they just give us a
little like xanax liquid when you enter
an airport so we're all just just
chilled out nothing matters we float
through I would be okay with that for
some people like I feel like some people
need that Karen yeah perfect Karen full
circle yeah I'm gonna be like so into it
or so against it either way the Karen's
will be involved well yeah would Karen's
like security theater because they love
the idea of everything being like
controlled and organized or do they hate
it because they would feel personally
called out by it and like who are you
ooh - look in my bag I think it's both
like they like when it's happening to
other people people who don't look like
them perhaps yeah you know you give them
the extra security clearance like what
are you talking about I'm not brown how
dare you yeah that's real that's real Oh
any other thoughts on on security
theater besides knowing that they
they're going up three times a week at
the Omaha Civic Center you can get
tickets for 1495 no check no temperature
checks at the security theater great so
I want to talk a little bit and we've
talked around this before about Kovac
conspiracies and I I'm nervous because
the topic I'm getting into wades into
heavy alec territory in terms of the the
anti-vaxxer community and health
conspiracies so I'm gonna just I'm gonna
say state that at the outset but the
reason why I have been thinking about
this is because it's it's hit a little
close to home and I'll tell you how I
started thinking about this and I think
I told Alec about this already but a
week or two ago my little sister what
blood very much who lives in Florida
this might be an important factor it
might not be if I'm gonna say it yeah
she asked me if I had she is the Florida
woman she had asked me if I'd seen
planned emic and I said did you
misspelled pandemic cuz I've seen of the
pandemic she's like no it's this this
video it's all over Facebook like
everyone on my Facebook feed is posting
it and arguing about it and I had not
heard of this thing once again she's in
Florida most of her friends are in
Florida this is the stuff they talk
about but you know I hadn't heard
anything about it and she said you know
seems a little sketchy but there's some
interesting arguments there what do you
think about it so I appreciate that she
like at least asked her big brother who
I think she knows to be a daughter with
a healthy dose of skepticism so like I
looked into it and of course as soon as
I googled it I found that I couldn't
watch it because YouTube and Facebook
had banned it for being dangerous and
convincing people of things like wearing
masks is dangerous because it will make
you sick not keep you from getting sick
a
a real thing that is discussed in it it
can tell you things like staying inside
is a plan to hurt your immune system and
they want you to stay in so you get sick
so you should both go outside without a
mask but you know I looked into it and
it's I don't look like - down the rabbit
hole and I also don't want to tell too
many details because I don't want to
give more amplification to these folks
but the version of it that made waves
and a couple weeks ago and came out it
was a 26 minute conspiracy theory video
which is said to be a trailer for a
full-fledged documentary that's coming
out this summer it's produced by a
California production company that's
it's called elevate I shouldn't even set
their name because we shouldn't give
them credit but of course it's a
California production company called
elevate that's already made a bunch of
kind of like [ __ ] conspiracy based
videos and there is a discredited former
medical researcher at the heart of all
this I don't even want to give her too
much credit who's someone who is clearly
been disgraced who published a [ __ ]
study who got kicked out of a research
center who doesn't even have a field of
expertise around this and the overall
themes of this you know short version of
the documentary are things like the
virus was created in a lab doctor foul
Qi is behind it masks are not good for
you staying inside is there to hurt you
hospitals get paid to claim people have
it so the reason the numbers are big is
because all these doctors are just like
stacking money and going on dope
vacations because all the cases and then
the kind of I think even more dangerous
thing that's happened and the Atlantic
did a full kind of issue spread about
this is our friends at queuing on have
latched on to many of the same theories
and I've avoided learning too much about
queuing on and other conspiracy stuff
kind of the way in which I know a lot of
us these days are like intentionally
avoiding going too deep into the news
because it can make us feel bad which is
fine if you're doing that I respect you
and I think that's maybe what you should
be doing is it's not like you're doing
anything to help and unless you're a
doctor or a nurse or a first responder
but um I've avoided and learning about
that because it really bums me out
and freaks me out but I read a bunch of
the articles and pieces that are part of
this Atlantic set of articles that came
out and it was it's very upsetting very
very upsetting in terms of how people
are latching on to this and in
connecting some of these coronavirus
conspiracies to other things the
Atlantic did a poll like a polling study
on conspiracy theories in general
including these and they found that
let's see almost everyone that they
surveyed believed in at least one of the
22 conspiracy theories they asked about
and was a lot of like you know the hits
of conspiracy theories only nine percent
of the respondents to the survey of the
Atlantic did didn't express any
agreement with any of the conspiracies
you know one examples twenty nine
percent of the respondents believe that
the threat of the virus is being
exaggerated to hurt Trump's chance at
reelection
I'm thirty one percent of people that
the Atlantic surveyed believe that the
virus was created and spread on purpose
and this whole narrative of the virus
being spread on purpose is one of the
main things in like these cue non
conspiracies and the play endemic
conspiracy theory thing the other reason
I went down this rabbit hole is a person
who I know from the Los Angeles comedy
community I never particularly liked if
I'm honest but seemed like they lived in
the in the swimming pool of rationality
has been radicalized by a lot of these
conspiracies their Facebook wall now
seems it's it's truly insane and this
person is talking about how it's sort of
like George Soros and Bill Gates along
with the deep state and Illuminati types
have created a series of viruses so that
we can all get vaccinated the vaccines
are meant to control us somehow this
also ties into like pedophile rings it's
really unhinged stuff and I think the
thing that's really freaked me out is
obviously my little sister god bless her
I don't think she's been radicalized by
this stuff I think she was like Oh
everyone's talking about it seems
interesting but then I've seen another
person who I didn't think was insane
before is now
losing friendships it looks like
fracturing relationships because they
believe in this like interconnected deep
state conspiracy thing and this kind of
it it freaks me out and it freaks me out
that something like a global pandemic is
being twisted in this way to facilitate
encourage and provide further webs of
connectivity to already existing
conspiracy theories now I know that
neither of you all believe in this stuff
I know like either of y'all like saw
this seeing this type of stuff pop up in
your world or social media feeds those
sorts of things or do I just know crazy
people well I was aware of planned emic
I haven't watched it just because
because let me say that - don't don't
watch it if you if you're hearing this
oh I'm doing if you were if you really
want to watch it you can go on I think
it's dr. Mike his YouTube channel he has
a video yeah and he has a video where he
basically plays the documentary but like
he talks you through it so at least if
you do it that way you don't get caught
up in the manipulative [ __ ] and dr.
Mike will be like pause here's why this
sucks
so maybe if you're gonna watch it watch
his thing yeah my favorite is like
they're paying doctors to lie and say
people have Cove it but yes he except he
explains it in this video that's just I
forgive it's Medicare and Medicaid but
you know the government has deals with
hospitals being like hey so like a heart
attack should cost well like I don't
know thirty thousand dollars treat
here's $30,000 if you have someone now
obviously there's something called fraud
and like someone a doctor who will
probably get prosecuted be like yeah I
treated like eighteen different heart
attacks but the Cova thing is no
different they're like here's the amount
of money that takes three to kovat
patient and you know I'm not saying of
the thousands and tens of thousands of
doctors out there that like maybe
someone hasn't committed some white
fraud for for money but no more than
they're claiming fraud on treating other
[ __ ] that Medicare pays them for so it's
[ __ ] ridiculous the doctor Mike video
is very good though even though he
defends us all that I hate
documents but I think what I find kind
of interesting all of this is centered
around Bill Gates
I don't know planned emic is but
something about yet overlaps with the
Bill Gates stuff yeah so I don't like
Bill Gates no Bo gate sucks I'm gonna
say it [ __ ] Bill Gates and we don't like
Bill Gates no I don't want to I don't
want to hate on anyone who likes it so
so he I'm gonna go on an anti Bill Gates
peel that is predicated even if you
think what the the Bill and Melinda
Gates Foundation is amazing they do
incredible work that's fine that like my
my criticism circumvent that but it's
like the conspiracies that Bill Gates
secretly controls the world once do all
this evil [ __ ]
the reality is Bill Gates has the sort
started an authoritarian control over
like democratic processes because he's a
billionaire and has no like
accountability that he thinks he's doing
like great work and I'm not saying like
he hasn't the boom what they haven't
done great things but the best example
there's a great book I just read called
pandemic by Sonya Shah and I think this
is in there if not I'll figure out but
it was in a book I read recently the
foundation really wants to eradicate
malaria which is the noble cause I
believe Bill Gates genuinely believes it
should be eradicated but if you ask any
public health expert this is a bad idea
it is not cost-effective it is much
cheaper to like control malaria and do
all these other strategies to make sure
you know treat treat it with drugs
develop new drugs to make sure that
people aren't dying from it and whether
or not you think we should eradicate it
or do the thing that public health
experts say is not even the point
but because like the Bill and Melinda
Gates Foundation is I think the fourth
or fifth largest donor to the World
Health Organization they're like here's
billions of dollars but only if you do
the exact thing we say so again like
it's not as bad because like he he's not
evilly trying to do the wrong thing but
the fact that just by virtue of having
billions of dollars you could control
the policy of this large seemingly
democratic organization that it's
supposed to like have input from around
the globe it's [ __ ] awful it's bad
it's bad for democracy it's bad for the
world and so stop it and like if you
want to hate on Bill Gates and how he's
controlling the world complain about
that not like invent some weird [ __ ]
about microchips
preach so many questions about Bill
Gates this whole time well I I think I
think he genuinely believes he's doing
the like I don't think that he's like
this evil guy like but also you know
most of the problems I have with him
have to do with the fact that as a
billionaire he gets to like control the
world
yeah yeah I would just yet same thing
just to be clear I'm not saying that
Bill Gates sucks in the way that the
conspiracist a he sucks I think he sucks
in the same way that a other super
powerful powerful rich dude suck yeah so
surveyed are you a conspiracy theorist
and are and or are you surrounded by
them in your physical and digital life I
am NOT a conspiracy theorist I have
heard of people repeating them though um
like oh do you think that coronavirus
started in a lab or oh did the Chinese
do this on purpose
or you know things like that and I'm
like yeah like what they came by doing
it on purpose like let's like walk
through that like let's assume yes and
let's like walk through how that how
they benefited so things like I have
heard of it and I it like I said it's
sort of like going out to dine with
friends or I realize like I hate them
and they're like I feel like I just
don't like having conversations with
people in my real life because I realize
like your whole conspiracy that's great
advice don't talk to people because they
might keep might be conspiracy theorists
I have a friend she was in a park and no
one was around so she took her mask off
I was like hanging or whatever someone
approaches her I'm not wearing a mask
hey I know she's not wearing her mask
can I ask you why and she thought she
was gonna get yelled at she's like oh it
just known was around and she's like oh
I thought you thought the virus wasn't
real like me no good I will say if
anyone does have because this stuff
happens and it is what it is if you have
like a wacky off-the-grid uncle or like
a weird alienated cousin or something
who
comes at you with this stuff there is a
life hacker article on it's called
something like what to say to people
that really like the plan Demick for
something like that but it's worth
checking now because it does have some
interesting points for how to interact
with someone and in Forbes had an
article as well kind of with a similar
theme that was like you know so your
friends are losing their minds here's
how to engage and interact and one of
the things of course is a lot of these
types of conspiracies they like preload
the people to believe it with this ideas
of like this is what your sheet bull
fringes are going to say to you so I
thought there was yeah so there's some
good stuff in the life hacker B's in
this Forbes piece that we're like you
know if you just run at them calling
them idiots it's going to further
confirm the [ __ ] they believe so here
are some ways to try to engage on
science so I'd say like you know if
anyone's in that position maybe try that
on I mean the really important question
is and I'll pose this to both of you do
we think that Carens are likely or
unlikely to be Kovach conspiracist they
are they're kovat conspiracy I think
there's a Venn diagram but I don't think
it's one for one yeah the only evidence
I've seen is that there are a few
prominent influencers who meet a lot of
care and stereotypes who are straight up
or going into conspiratorial stuff now a
couple of them I don't know their names
cuz I don't care enough but like
big-time care enough care enough who are
big-time influencers have started to
post like coded messages and stuff like
that
about stuff like this so they're
probably gonna lose their sponsors and
then say that Bill Gates did it Wow okay
so so that's that's all about thats
alright that bummed anyone out but now
the most important part of this show is
when we hear from you our friends our
viewers our listeners our family and if
you are one of those people already
great if you haven't yet taking that
dive of joining the family here's how
you can do it you can leave us a
voicemail call us at 1 2 1 3 5 3 4 8 8 0
7 once again that's 1 2 1 3 5 3 4 8 8 0
7 um I do have to say just to be clear
that is not Alec's personal number you
cannot text them at night we
had a lot of people making a mistake so
please don't do DM me and I will give
you Alex phone number but that is not it
and then you can email us at culture
binge at wisecrack dot co no m their
culture ban jet wisecrack co so as
always we'd love to hear from you and
especially if you have thoughts on the
Karen lifestyle security theater or if
you've had some weird experiences
recently with friends and family falling
down the weird rabbit hole Cova
conspiracy would love to hear about that
but this week I think Alec we have some
emails so I just wanna say I want to
hear from like have there been I always
want the redemption story are there
redeemed Karen's change in the world
yeah I want that I used to be a Karen
until one day out of TGI Fridays I had a
recognized Wow like the reformed gap
that's I would love to hear that anyway
the first email comes from Amanda who
wanted to share with you my experiences
in Animal Crossing my husband and I
share an island where he owns the game
but I live there too and can make some
changes while my husband was furloughed
he planned a date for us on our island
this was really nice because between the
stay-at-home order and being a parent
with two kids under 4 wow we were able
to have a date night without leaving
home it also showed that he actually
thought and planned out something that
he thought I would like like a bench
near the seashore so we could watch the
sunset together Oh fellas take notes
that's incredible
today is my birthday happy birthday even
though years ago and he stepped up again
and planned a scavenger hunt on our
island what he did was customized how
with little messages and place them
around our island sent letters and
posted on the island community board to
lead me to happy birthday message with
presents for my character if anyone's
partner has not done this for them break
up with them right now it's over don't
do that well but anyone anyone whose
partner doesn't listen to this for you
listen to it and do that and just say
it's an original idea that came to you
and it'll get you points yeah they did
say that their partner found it in a
video on YouTube but don't be like that
sorry your partner's dumb you should
don't don't admit to that you came up
with the idea all on your own and also
this person sent us images which we
can't show right now but but they're
very cute of the of the island I didn't
get that email Wow
I thought you read them all sir I didn't
know I don't think it was Sun - I didn't
see it well I read all the emails no I
do read all the emails I'm kidding about
[ __ ] with you alright the next one is
an email from Jesse it says high culture
binge sorry
high culture binge I thought some light
could be shed on how you cultivate these
qualities sorry Jesse said a bunch of
nice things I'm not gonna repeat them
because I'm shy but he essentially gave
a very personalized complement to each
of us but anyway Jesse wanted to know
shed some light on how we cultivate our
amazing qualities by asking the three of
us if we have any sort of structure on
how to consume articles media and the
like ie what is your content regimen
I would love some specific sites apps
etc if possible thank you all for the
amazing work Wow yeah let's start with
surbhi I don't know so I read The
Economist um I also read there's like a
magazine from The Economist I think it's
like 1847 or something I read that from
The Economist I also read the Atlantic
hacker news I like New Yorker and the
New York Times I read The Wall Street
Journal and I also read like random
things like Oh what is that site called
a wired and sometimes they find
interesting things on LinkedIn and like
on the right side they'll have like a
little news thing I'll read that and
also I have it like a secret hidden
Twitter account that I like follow
really interesting people who will post
really interesting things appeared
Alecto
that's my that's my consumption last oh
you go yeah go go Michael oh sure I'll
go really quick that's such a good
question and I'm just gonna go off to
that in my head the things that normally
check during today and I'll say this
every publication I read there's stuff I
like on it and there's people I truly
hate on it so you do have to be
discerning but I do check the LA Times
in York Times most days I like the New
York magazine in particular I like
vulture their culture coverage and then
for culture coverage I also like AV Club
a good amount
let's see besides that I like to read
about food stuff so I do read like eater
and grub Street and things like that to
learn what's going on in the world of
food follow a lot of writers I'd like on
Twitter and a lot of my favorite writers
and people on Twitter are people that
wrote for publications that I'd loved
that got shut down so like there's a
publication online called the outline
that got killed recently a lot of their
writers are really fantastic and a lot
of them are great Twitter follows I used
to love a website called Splinter there
was a politics website run by the people
who did like Gawker and Jezebel love all
those writers they recently started a
new thing called the discourse um it's a
website and a blog newsletter thing that
I like a lot
obviously Grateful Dead reddit is a good
source for a lot of things and then for
pop culture stuff I also like the ringer
a good amount to read about like takes
on movies and TV shows there and the
ringer I enjoy because it's right at the
intersection of kind of like dumb pop
culture consumption and smart people
giving takes on it and I think one of
the best examples of ringer content
would be like the binge mode podcast if
you love people that are geeks and the
best way possible about certain shows
and movies but we're also really
freaking smart people who I think of as
I feel like if we if wisecrack folks
hung out then we'd all get along I like
that stuff a lot as well but that's just
a mixed bag and I'm sure thank you so
much for being asking a question
Alec you've had time to prepare you read
the emails I didn't provide knowledge
I'm gonna start with what's bad about my
content consumption you guys are much
better than me because I would say most
of it comes from like the feeds of
Reddit and Twitter which I love dearly
but the problem with that is that I'm
making the number up here I don't know I
see like 200 headlines
and maybe I'll read them from like a
variety of sources and so you know I I
do find like long very informative
articles that are really amazing and
then I just see some headlines that are
oftentimes misleading that I'm
constantly bombarded with one thing that
I've been a little bit off this boat I
don't really off ever since Gawker shut
down I don't really consume news like
from you know like an Atlantic or New
York Times or Wall Street or whatever
like specific current events podcast
like Planet Money is a great usually the
like kind of money's a great podcast
Radiolab is like science but often times
it intersects with things going on so
like instead of knowing exactly like who
and the Trump administration is doing
what I just know about like very weird
and timely economic policies so there's
that for a while I was reading The New
Yorker but it took up so much time
because I would insist on reading an
article that I didn't have time to read
other things so I stopped but New York
was also really great but I'd say most
of my consumption comes from books and I
think the the trap that I've escaped or
I think I've escaped that is my advice
is like I try to read [ __ ] that I don't
necessarily consider in my comfort zone
and so like I've recently loved Walt not
recently but before the pandemic going
to the library and just like seeing what
kind of looked interesting like oh I
don't read about food let me read this
book about food or you know I've been
reading all about science which is
really outside my wheelhouse what I did
before is just read like 18 million
philosophy books usually about the same
exact things and so I'd say like most of
my media consumption is like book
centric and again like it's often better
than the news in that like you sure you
could read like a 500 word story or you
could read the sort of very long thing
about like pandemics and how they affect
our current world wow that's good and
you just want to throw um so I should
have said this before best piece of
advice that have for anyone find writers
you like follow them on Twitter and then
see what their reposting and what they
like because like like anything in this
world find out who you like and see what
their influences are or what you know
gets them to think the stuff they think
so that's a fun rabbit hole to go down
put a great question
and what do you read I'd like to know
because I don't remember you saying it
in your email so please write back
all right a great question the last one
is from raw yes Ross Ross writes hi from
Norwich England this is in relation to
what Michael was talking about the
absence of laughs tracks on late-night
shows I guess he means audience is
probably in this case but now over here
in England we know about live tracks but
I find us late-night shows almost
unbearable as the crowd yell way too
much enthusiastically too mediocre jokes
even when Jon Stewart was at the helm
this was the case when Coronas over
maybe they can get the audience to help
middle or improve the writing maybe get
Charlie Brooker to write for them
spikenard yeah yeah
love you guys loads and you all have
warming smiles it's so nice even Michael
Schneider seems to be smiling more than
he used to
oh that's so good to hear the meds are
working on jokes kind of maybe that's a
good point though I do think like if
anyone has a chance to ever watch some
UK late-night shows whether it's like
Mock the Week or Jools Holland or
whatever it might be they feel a lot
more organic and looser and the audience
interaction does feel less forced and I
do think just in general in particular
watch a celebrity interview on Jools
Holland or something and compare it to
how celebrities act on American
late-night shows and it really is night
or day so there's a lot we can learn
from British late-night shows the last
I'm not gonna read the whole email but
you were asked if there's a movie who
would play and Joe Rosen email I would
like the rock to play everybody but a
different costume per person yes is a
good answer Wow
I mean just to remind it too we have
insane by we I mean me I've been
obnoxiously saying go review and rate
and subscribe to the podcast and tell us
in your comments who you would want to
play each of us in a movie or just do it
in an email and even if you agree with
that one and you think there's no better
answer than the rock and different
costumes just keep saying that that's
great
it was that all for the emails that's it
wolf reminder wisecrack sorry culture
binge a wisecrack dot CEO for an email
yeah great and two one three five three
four eight eight oh seven if you want to
give us a call rate review say weird
stuff in the comments as long as you
give us a good rating but we'll be back
in two weeks
Allegan survey i have a good one I'm
gonna say have a good one to myself and
bye everyone
[Music]